without us perhaps quite noticing much
of what we place our hopes in will be
ready for us in a very long time indeed
in months or even decades from now if
ever the successful completion of a
novel a sufficient sum of money to buy a
house or begin a new career the
discovery of a suitable partner a move
to another country in the list of our
most intensely felt hopes few entries
stand to come to fruition this season or
next let alone by tonight but
occasionally life places us in a
situation where our normal long-range
hopeful way of thinking grows impossible
imagine you've had a car accident a very
bad one for weeks it seemed like you
might not make it at all now
you're out of a coma and back home but
you still have multiple broken bones
serious bruises and constant meat grain
it's unclear from here when you'll be
going back to work or whether you ever
will when someone asks how things are
one answer seems to fit above all we're
taking it one day at a time
imagine that a person is 89 mentally
agile but very slow on their feet and
often in pain they had a fool last month
and the left knee is badly arthritic
yesterday they did some gardening today
they may go to the shops for the first
time in a while you ask their carer how
they are we're taking it one day at a
time oh you're a new parent it was a
very difficult birth the baby had
jaundice and required a blood
transfusion and now finally mother and
child are home the baby cries a lot in
the night and has to take some medicines
that aggravate the stomach but last
night was good enough and hopefully
today if the weather holds there's a
chance of taking a trip to the park to
see the daffodils how's it all going
we're taking it one day at a time
these may be extreme scenarios and a
natural impulse is to hope that we will
never encounter them but they contain
valuable teachings for anyone with a
tendency to ignore their own advantages
that is for all of us one day at a time
thinking reminds us that in many cases
our greatest enemy is that otherwise
critical nectar hope and the perplexing
emotion it tends to bring with it
impatience by limiting our horizons -
tonight we're girding ourselves for the
long haul and remembering that an
improvement may best be achieved when we
manage not to await it too ardently our
most productive mood may be acquired
melancholy with which we can ward off
the temptations of rage or mania and
fully imbibe the moderates steadfastness
required to do fiddly things write a
book bring up a child repair a marriage
or work through a mental breakdown
taking it day by day
means reducing the degree of control we
expect to be able to bring to bear on
the uncertain future it means
recognizing that we have no serious
capacity to exercise our will on a span
of years and should not therefore
disdain a chance to secure one or two
minor wins in the hours ahead of us we
should from a new perspective count
ourselves immensely grateful if by
nightfall
there have been no further arguments and
no more seizures if the rain is let off
and we found one or two interesting
pages to read as life as a whole grows
more complicated we can remember to
unplug and smile a little along the way
rather than jealously husbanding our
reserves of joy for a finale somewhere
in the nebulous distance given the scale
of what we're up against
knowing that perfection may never occur
and that far worse may be coming our way
we can stoop to accept with fresh
gratitude a few of the minor gifts that
are already within our grasp we might
look with fresh energy at a cloud a duck
a butterfly or a flower at 22 we might
scoff at such suggestions for there
seemed so many larger grander things to
hope for than these evanescent
manifestations of nature romantic love
career fulfillment or big political
change but with time almost all one's
more revolutionary aspirin
Asians tend to take a hit perhaps a very
large hit one encounters some of the
intractable problems of intimate
relationships one suffers the gap
between one's professional hopes and the
available realities one has a chance to
observe how slowly and fitfully the
world ever alters in a positive
direction one is fully inducted to the
extent of human wickedness and folly and
to one's own eccentricity selfishness
and madness and so natural beauty may
take on a different hue no longer a
petty distraction from a mighty destiny
no longer an insult to ambition but a
genuine pleasure amidst the litany of
troubles an invitation to bracket
anxieties and keep self-criticism at bay
a small resting place for hope in a sea
of disappointment a proper consolation
for which one is finally ready on an
afternoon walk to be appropriately
grateful Vincent van Gogh was admitted
to the sampled mental asylum in surimi
in southern France in May of 1889 having
lost his mind and tried to sever his ear
at the start of his stay he mostly lay
in bed in the dark after a few months he
grew a little stronger and was able to
go out into the garden and it was here
that he noticed in a legendary act of
concentrated aesthetic absorption that
gnarled roots of a southern pine the
blossom on an apple tree a caterpillar
on its way across a leaf and most
famously the bloom of a succession of
purple irises in his hands these became
like the totemic symbols of a new
religion oriented towards a celebration
of the transcendent beauty of the
everyday his vars with irises is no
sentimental study of a common flower it
is the work of a pivotal figure in
Western culture struggling to make it to
the end of the day without doing himself
in and clinging on very tightly indeed
with the hands of a genius - a reason to
live it's normal enough to hold out for
all that we want why would we celebrate
hobbling when we want to run why accept
friendship when we crave passion but if
we reach the end of the day and no one
has died no further limbs have broken
a few lines have been written and one or
two encouraging and pleasant things have
been said then that is already an
achievement worthy of a place at the
altar of sanity how natural and tempting
to put one's faith in the bountifulness
of the years but how much wiser it might
be to bring all one's faculties of
appreciation and love to bear on that
most modest and most easily dismissed of
increments the day already in hand
the school of life is coming to New York
from the 4th to the 6th of October for a
three-day conference or you'll have the
chance to meet other like-minded
individuals and embark on a journey of
genuine self-discovery and self
transformation we hope to see you there